9. sınıf tayfam. Herkese iyi çalışmalar,
kolaylıklar. Rehber matematikte ben
Deniz Mehmet hocanızla birlikte 9. sınıf
matbook serimizde marif modele uygun bir
şekilde ilerlemeye devam ediyoruz.
Kitabımızdan sayfa 23'ü açıyorsun, sayfa
24'ü açıyorsun. Buraları beraber canını
okuyacağız. Şimdi sonrasında da yine
devam edecek seri halde videolarımız.
Kitaba ulaşmak isteyen arkadaşlar için
videonun açıklama kısmına bırakacağım.
Yorumlara sabitleyeceğim. Yetmez
rehbermatematik.com'a da dileyen
arkadaşlara PDF bırakacağım. Ama önce
biraz yorum okumak istiyorum. Muhammed
yazmış bir önceki videoya bundan sonra
yorumları okuyacağız arkadaşlar. Hocam
ben konuları ilk başta anlamıyorum ama
sizi izledikten sonra hemen anlıyorum.
Teşekkür ederim hocam. Ben sana teşekkür
ederim. Niye? Yorumla da bir de
gelmişsin burada destek oluyorsun. Hocam
Allah razı olsun sizden demiş Eylül
Eken. Çok teşekkür ediyorum. Senden de
Allah razı olsun. Maafsa Fasivasio gibi
bir şey. Abi seviliyorsun çok iyi
videolar yapıyorsun demiş. Eyvallah
diyelim. Yuva yıkan hocam izlemedim
videoyu. 9. sınıfa başladım. Tüonuz var
mı? 9. sınıf hakkında günü gününe gelen
bütün Marif Model MacBook 9. sınıf seri
videolarımızı izle. İleride gelecek olan
tekrar videoları ve aynı zamanda deneme
videolarını da kaçırma diyelim.
Özellikle bunu söyleyeyim. Sağ olun
hocam demiş. Cansın abi demiş. İlk demiş
hocam geçen yılki videonuzda devam
ediyorum demiş. Arkadaş ben yeni
videolar çekiyorum. Oradan da devam
etmeni şiddetle öneririm. Hocam
enerjiniz kaybolmuş resmen. Kim sömürdü
sizi? demiş. Yorgun bir videoya falan
denk gelmiş olabilirsin Resul. Vallahi
kusura bakma ama enerjim bugün yerimde.
Abi sen de olmasan biz ne yaparız demiş.
Doktor Strange. Ey Dror Strange ben
buradayım. Sen oradasın. Elinde kalemin
önünde kitabın hazır mı? Diğer bütün
tayfada gönder gelsin diyelim. Sorun o
56'dayız arkadaş. Burada bir şey
söyleyeyim vallaha var. Ben burayı
çektim arkadaşlar geçen videoda bu 59'un
sonuna kadar çektim. Tam burada sesuşle
buralar gözükmedi videoda. Artık burayı
baştan çekiyoruz. Yapacak bir şey yok.
Gel. Sorun o 56. İşlemin sonucunu
arıyoruz beraber. Hocam kök içerisinde
ifadeler var. Bu işleme nasıl
gidiyorduk? Bak şimdi bu arkadaş bunu
götürüyordu ama dışarı çıkarken nasıl
çıkartıyordum? Mutlak değerce
çıkartıyordum ama onun önünde ne var?
Eksi var. -5 mutlağın içerisinde. 49
dediğim sayı 7nin karesidir. Bunlar
gitti. Mutlağa gerek var mı? Gerek yok.
Direkt 7 olarak çıkartabilirim. Cırt
sana. Cırt sana. Bunlar gitti. Eksi eksi
şuradan geliyor. Mutlak değerce ne kaldı
hocam içeride? -14 kaldı. Noktayı
koydum. Olayı bitirdim. Buraya kadar
anlaşılmayan bir noktamız var mı? Güzel.
Şimdi bak şu arkadaşları götürdüm. Ama o
arkadaş da dışarı çıkarken nasıl
çıkmalı? Mutlak değerce çıkmalı. Şimdi
bunun cevabı zaten 5 ama önünde eksi
olduğu için -5'i koruyacak. Yoksa
mutlaktan dolayı + 5'e doğru gitmek
istiyordu. +7 buradan geldi. Burası da
yine 14 olarak çıkar dışarı ama önünde
eksi olduğu için -14. Bu arkadaşı direkt
+4 olarak dışarı çıkartabilirim. Şuradan
ne geldi? 2 geldi. Yukarıdaki işlemi
yaptığımda -12/4 var. Böl bak birbirine
ne geliyor. -3. Tertemiz işçilik.
Sınavda belki böyle bir soru gelebilir.
Şimdi iç içe kökler olunca şartlar
değişiyor mu hocam? Katian. Orada da bir
değişikliğimiz yok. 3. dereceden kökümü
koydum. 21'imi koydum. Bak en dipten
başlayacağım. + √31'imi koydum.
Tamamdır. Geldim buna. √25in karesidir.
Karekökü götürür. 5 diye buraya çıkar
koyarım. + 5. Buraya kadar sıkıntı yok.
31 5 daha ne yapar? 36 yapar. O zaman
devam. 3. dereceden √21 + 36 aslında 6ın
karesidir. Kare bunu götürür. Dışarı
nasıl çıkar? 6 olarak çıkar. 3.
dereceden kök içerisi 27 oldu. E 27
dediğimiz sayı 3'ün 3. dereceden
kuvvetidir. Bunlar sadeleşir. Cevabımız
sadece 57. soruda 3'tür. Geldim 58'e.
Bak bu önemli ayrıntı bir soru. Burada
şunu söyleyeyim özellikle. Eğer ki a
0'dan küçükse mutlak içerisinde a
ifadesi dışarı nasıl çıkar? Arkadaş
mutlaklı ifadelerde içerisi negatifse ki
a 0'dan küçük söylüyor soruda. Dışarı
işaret değiştirip çıkar. Burada enfikir
miyiz? Hocam benim elimde bıdan büyük.
Mutlak B dışarı nasıl çıkar? Mutlak
telin işaretine bakacaksın her zaman.
İçerideki işaret ne? Artı aynen çıkar.
Artıysa aynen çıkar. Eksi ise işaret
değiştir çıkar. Şimdi kural bu. Bunu
sadece hatırlattım. Soruda bana diyor ki
a 0'dan küçük olsun. B de 0'dan büyük
olan sayılar olsun. Benim elimde bu var.
Bunun cevabını bana bulur musun? Gel
bulalım. Şimdi ilk olarak benim köklü
ifadeden kurtulmam lazım değil mi? 4
gitti. 4 dereceden kök gitti. Ama çift
dereceden kökte ne yapıyorduk hocam?
Dışarı çıkarırken a - b mutlak içinde
yazıyorduk. Cırt sana, cırt sana dışarı
çıkarırken ne yapıyorduk? A diye
çıkarıyorduk. Cırt sana, cırt sana
dışarı çıkarırken ne yapıyorum? Mutlak
içinde çıkartıyorum. Şimdi benim şuna
karar vermem lazım. Hocam mutlaklı
ifadelerin içerisi pozitif mi negatif
mi? A'dan B'yi çıkartıyorsun. Hiç mi
göremedin? Ver abiciğim sayı. İstediğin
sayıyı ver fark etmez aslında. A sayısı
küçük sayısı, b sayısı büyük sayıdır. Al
sana bir tüyoda. Matematik öğreniyoruz
ya. Küçük sayıdan büyük sayı çıkarsa
cevap daima negatif. Geldim. Büyük
sayıdan küçük sayı çıkarsa cevap daima
pozitiftir. Bu şaşmaz kural bizim için.
O zaman diyorum ki A sayısı küçük sayı,
B sayısı büyük sayısı içerisinde
kesinlikle negatif. Hocam B zaten
pozitif olduğunu ben buradan görüyorum.
Bunun cevabı da pozitif. Şimdi amaç
mutlak değerin dışına çıkmak. İçerisi
negatifse dışarı nasıl çıkıyordum hocam?
İşaret değiştirip + a dışarı -a çıktı.
-b dışarı + b çıktı. Kabul müyüz?
Yanında ne var? + a'sı var. Bu B pozitif
dışarı aynen çıkar ama önünde eksisi
var. O zaman -b. Cırt sana, cırt sana,
cırt sana, cırt sana. Ne kaldı bana?
Koskoca bir sıfır kaldı. Hepsi birbirini
götürdü. Sivas'a selam olsun.
Üniversiteyi orada okumuştum. Kaldığım
yıllarda da çok memnundum. Tüm Sivaslı
arkadaşlara selam olsun. Vallah
diğerleri kızmasın ama. Vallah orada
okuduğum için özel. Şimdi geldim 59.
soruya. Bir kargo şubesinde eşit kollu
terazinin kefelerine iki farklı koli
yerleştirilmiş. Kolilerin kütleleri
kilogram cinslerinden üzerlerine
yazılmış. Bak kütleleri de burada
yazılmış. Buna göre terazinin
dengelenmesi için hangi ağırlık blokları
tek başına mavi kollu kolinin kevesine
konulabilir? Yani buraya neyi koyarsam
dengeye gelir? Dengeye gelmesi için ne
olması lazım? Eşitlik durumunda dengeye
gelir. O zaman benim önce şunlara karar
vermem lazım. Hocam burası aslında kök
içerisinde 12'nin karesidir. Yani sıra
kısaca burada 12 birimlik bir ağırlık
var. Tamam. Geldim. 289
289 neyin karesiydi falan diye
düşüneceğiz şimdi değil mi? Harbiden
neyim ya bu? 81 x 3 desem 3 x 1 3 3 x 8
243 yetmedi ha 17'ydi bak hatırladım
hocam bu sayı aslında 17'nin karesidir.
Bak ezbere bazen bilmekte fayda var.
Cırt sana cırt sana bunlar gitti. Burada
da 17 birimlik ağırlık var. Demek ki
benim buraya ekleyeceğim ağırlık + 5
birim olacak ki dengeye gelsin. O zaman
derdimiz ne? Cevabı 5 olan cevaplar
benim istediklerim. Şimdi geldim buraya.
3. dereceden 125 var. 125 dediğim sayı
5'in 3. kuvveti. Bunlar gitti dışarı
aynen çıktı. Cevap kaç? 5. Geldim. -5in
karesi. Şimdi bu kare bunu götürür ama
dışarı çıkarken mutlak değerce çıkar. Bu
da 5. Evet. Geldim. 4. dereceden 256 kök
içerisinde. Hocam bu değer aslında 4'ün
4. kuvvetidir. 16'nın karesidir aslında.
Ya da öyle yazalım ya da yok 4'ün 4.
kuvveti daha güzel oldu. Niye? Şunlar
birbirini götürdü. Direkt dışarı 4 diye
çıktı. Peki benimkini hangisi sağlıyor?
Cevabı 5 olanlar sağlar. Kısaca pembe ve
sarı olanları koyarsam oradaki sol
tarafa denge şartı sağlanmış olur.
Anlaştık mı? Şimdi geleni bir başlık
atalım. Kök dışına çıkarma ve kök içine
alma. Sayıları biz dilersek kökün dışına
nasıl çıkarıyoruz, nasıl alıyoruz ona
bakacağız. Ama bazen sayının tamamı
çıkmayabilir. Hani az önce yaptığımız
örneklerde kökün derecesi ile sayılar
aynıydı. Dereceleri. Eee o zaman ne
diyorduk? Direkt dışarı
çıkarabiliyorduk. En azından mutlak
derecede de olsa. Bazen sayının tamamı
çıkmayacak. Bak şimdi a da 0'dan b de
0'dan büyük eşit olsun. N de bir tam
sayı olsun. Yani n dediğimiz sayıyı aynı
zamanda 2'den büyük eşit olsun ki kök
derecesi olarak yazacağız. Kökün
içindeki bir çarpanın üssü kök
derecesine eşitse ki yapıyorduk. Çarpan
kök dışına çıkabilir. Yani ne diyorsun
hocam? Bak şuradaki n'eradeleşiyordu.
Bu a tek başına dışarı çıkıyordu. Ama
içeride kim kaldı? Öb ifadesi ama n
dereceden ök b ifadesi kaldı. O dışarı
çıkamadı. Bir de burada önemli bir şey
var. Eğer n tekse tamam böyle
çıkartabilirsin ama n çse nasıl
çıkaracağız? Mutlak değerce çıkaracağız.
Onu da unutmayalım ama ben burada
hatırlatmasını yapmış olayım. Misal bak
şuradaki ifadeye. 3'ün 5. dereceden
kuvveti çarpı 2 5 dereceden kökün
içerisine şu şunu götürdü bu arkadaş
dışarı 3 diye çıktı mı? Çıktı ama bu
kaldı. Kökün derecesi ile birlikte
içeride kalacak. Nasıl dışarı
çıkarıyorsam aynı şekilde içeri de
alabilirim. Peki içeri alma olayı nedir?
Bak bu a'yı alacağız. Burada kökün
içerisine alacağım. Hocam buradaki kökün
derecesi kaç? N. İçeri girerken üst
olarak almam gerekir. Üst olarak almam
lazım. Bak a üssü x b. Şimdi ne oldu? N
dereceden kökümü geri yazdım. Gerçekten
bu bunu götürüp bu arkadaş dışarı
çıkabilir mi? Normalde A şeklinde
çıkabilir ki zaten dışarıday. Ben ne
yaptım? Onu içeriye aldım. Var mı
sıkıntı? Yok. Gel bak örneğine. 2 x 3
dereceden √7 ifadesi var. Bu ifadeyi
alacağım içeri hocam. İçeri girerken ne
olur? 2 üstüne bunu kuvvet olarak alır.
Çarpı 7'si yanında kalacak mı? Kalacak.
3. dereceden kuvveti kalacak. Peki 2
üzeri 3'ü nedir? 8. 7 kere 8 nedir? 56.
56. 3. dereceden √56. Ama bir kez daha
hatırlatmakta fayda var. Hocam eğer n
çiftse ve a negatifse bu arkadaş dışarı
çıkarken nasıl çıkmak zorundaydı? Mutlak
değerci. Onu unutmayacağın sadece. Zaten
bir önceki bölümde onu anlattım. Hocam
peki bu arkadaş dışarı nasıl çıkar? Önce
çarpanını ayır. Dışarı çıkabilecek
şekilde. 16 x 2 midir? E 16 dediğim sayı
4'ün karesi midir? E4'ün karesi şununla
şu sadeleşti dışarı 4 diye. √2'si kaldı
diyeceksin bana. Peki hocam yazdık. 25 x
3 müdür burası? E 25 dediğim sayı 5in
karesi mi? Evet. E kare ile bu gitti
dışarı 5 diye çıktı. √3 içeride kaldı
hocam. Harikasın. 125 nedir hocam? 125
dediğim sayı 25 x 5'tir. 125'i verir. E
25'in 5in karesi olduğunu söyledik.
Kareler gitti. Dışarı 5 diye çıktı ama
kökü içeride kaldı. 5√5.
98. Düşün bakalım nedir bu sayı? Aslında
49'un 2 katıdır değil mi? 49 nedir
hocam? 7in karesidir. 7nin karesinden
dolayı kök gitti. Burası ne oldu? 7√2
oldu. Yakaladık mı? Gel. √50. Hocam 25 x
2 midir? Evet. 25 dediğim sayı nedir?
5in karesidir. O dışarı nasıl çıkar? 5
diye çıkar. İçeride ne kalır? 5√2 kalır.
72 dediğim sayı nedir? 36 x 2'dir. 36
6ın karesidir. Kareden dolayı kendini
dışarı attı. İçeride ne kaldı? 6√2
kaldı. Güzel mi? Devam. 3. dereceden √54
var. O zaman benim burada 3. dereceden
bir kuvvet yazmam gerekiyor. O zaman
nedir? Bak 27 çarpı nedir? 54'tür. E 27
dediğim sayı neydi? 3'ün 3. kuvvetiydi.
E hocam 3'ünün 3. kuvveti bunlar gitti.
Bu arkadaş dışarı 3 diye çıktı ama
içerideki arkadaş kaldı. 486 ama 5.
dereceden kökün içinde. Demek ki buraya
5. dereceden bir kuvvet yazacağım.
Mesela aklıma gelmiyor değil mi? Diyorum
ki 486 çift bir sayı. 2'ye bölsem 2 4 3
243 gelir. E 243 dediğim sayı da 3'ün 5.
kuvvetidir. O zaman ben aslında 3'ün 5.
kuvveti çarpı 2 mi yazacağım buraya? E
bu kuvvet şunu götürür. Bu arkadaş
dışarı 3 diye çıkar. 5. dereceden √2
burada kalır mı? Kalır. Aman diyeyim.
Oradaki dereceleri. Unutma. Bunları yaz.
Şimdi yaptığım işlem neydi benim hocam?
Biz kökün dışına çıkardık. Bravo. Şimdi
kökün içine almaya bakacağız. Bu arkadaş
içeri nasıl girecek? Şimdi kökü
yazıyorsun. Kökün derecesi kaç? 2. Demek
ki 3 içeri girerken hani şapkasına
takıyormuş gibi düşün. İçeri şapkayı
taktı girdi. E 3'ün karesi kaç? 9. E 9la
10'u çarptığın ne geldi? 90. √90. Devam.
5 içeri girecek. Kökün derecesine bak.
2. Hiçbir şey yazmıyorsa 2. X e 5in
karesi neydi? 25 25'yı çarpalım. 6 kere
5 30 elimde var. 3 12 3 daha ne yaptı?
150 √150
7 içeri almam lazım 7 bak burada 2 var
7in karesi olarak geldi. Yani 49 x 3
oldu. 3 x 9 27 dur yazamadık. Elde var 2
3 k 12 3 daha 157 kök içerisinde 157 çok
enteresan geldi. 3 kere 9 27 doğru
çarptık. Tamam. Bu arkadaş içeri nasıl
girecek? 3. dereceden kuvvet var ya 4'ün
3. kuvveti olarak girdi. İçeride de bir
de kaç çarpanı var? 4. Bu sefer sayıyı
bulmayacağım. Sadece üslü sayı biçiminde
yazacağım. Tabanlar aynı çarpım
durumunda üstleri topluyorum. 3 üssü 4
üssü 1 ile 4 üssü 3. Üstleri topla 4
üssü 4 gelir. Devam. Bu arkadaş içeri
girebilir hocam. Nasıl girer? 3.
dereceden kuvvet 2 üssü 3 x 11. E bu 8
yapar. 8ile 11'i çarp. 3. dereceden kök
88. Bu da benim aradığım cevap olur. Bu
arkadaş içeri çok rahat girer. 3.
dereceden kök 2 üsü 3 x 4 e 2 üssü kaç?
3 kaçtı? 8'di. 4 kere 8 ne yaptı? 32
yaptı. 3. dereceden √32. Şimdi bunlar
tamamen bu işin pratik kısmı. Sınavda ne
gelir hocam? Gel. Okul sınavında gelse
gelse eğer sadece bu bölümle ilgili soru
gelecekse böyle gelir. A ve B 1 birden
farklı birer pozitif tam sayı olmak
üzere kök içerisinde 72 = a x √ eşitliğe
göre a + b'nin alabileceği farklı
değerleri bulunuz. Şimdi hepsi için
farklı değerler düşüneceğim dışarı
çıkarabileceğim. Değil mi? Ama neyden
farklı? 1den farklı. Yani şunu
yapamazsın diyor. Bak hile yapma diyor
sana. 1 x √72. Normalde 1 + 72 derim.
Cevap ne derim? 73 derim. Ama adam
özellikle diyor bak A da B de 1den
farklı. A burada 1 olduğu için bu
ihtimali alamazsın. Bunu ele o zaman
başka düşünelim hocam. √72 mesela ne ile
neyin çarpımı 72'dir? 36 x 2'nin. Doğru
mu? 36 dışarı nasıl çıkar? 6 diye çıkar.
6√2 oldu mu? İstediğin formatı aldı mı?
O zaman 6 2 daha cevap ne geldi? 8. Bak
bu olabilir mesela. Bu benim istediğim
değerlerden biridir. Geldim yine √72'yi
dışarı çıkaracağım hocam.
4ile de çarpıncı oluyor sanki. 4 de
böldüm yani. 4e böldüm. Kaç defa var?
Bir defa var. 32 4 kere 8 32 4 kere 8 32
elde var. 3 72 sağladı. 4 dışarı nasıl
çıkar? 2 diye çıkar. 2√1 benim aradığım
cevap olabilir mi hocam? Olabilir. Peki
ben 2 + 18'den cevaba nasıl ulaşırım? 20
ulaşırım. Çünkü benden şurada
oluşturduğum değerlerin toplamını
istiyor. Devam ettim. √72'yi ben şöyle
de yazarım hocam. 9 kere 8 72'dir. 9
burada dışarı çıkabilir. 9 dışarı 3 diye
çıkar. 3√8 olur. E buradan da ben artık
3 ve 8'i bulduğum için 3le 8'i topladım.
Toplam ne geldi? 11 geldi. 3 tane farklı
değer bulduk mu? Değil mi? Bulduk. 8
var. 20 var. Bir de 11 var. Benim
alabileceğim değerler 3 tanedir. Hani
benim aklıma başka gelmiyor. Senin
geliyorsa söyle. A + B'nin alabileceği
farklı değerleri bulunuz. Şöyle yazalım
istersen bak. A + B'nin olabileceği
değerler hocam. 8 olur, 11 olur, bir de
20 olur. Alabileceğimiz değerler
bunlardır dedim. Noktayı koydum ama
bizim noktalar öyle boş değil arkadaş.
Kamp boyunca benimle birlikte kitap kaç
sayfaydı? Bak bakalım. 262
sayfa boyunca benimle birlikte hepsine
ne istiyorum senden? Tek tek tik
atacaksın. Tamam mı? Bu tikleri beraber
atıyor olacağız. Attık 23. sayfaya
geldim. Yeni sayfaya. Burayı da
anlatacağız. Şu aşağıya kadar 9'a kadar.
Sonrasında sıralanışı, köklü ifadelerin
sıralanışı ve kalan kısmı bir sonraki
derse bırakacağım. Tamam. Kök
derecesinde genişletme ve sadeleştirme
yapabiliriz. Neden? Neden ne olacak?
Hocam bir kere şöyle bir şey var mı? 2
üzeri 3 üslü sayı değil mi? Ben bu üslü
sayının aslında paydasında kaç
görüyorum? 1. E bu bir rasyonel sayı
oldu. İstersem paydayı 2 ile
genişletemez miyim? Sayı değişmesin diye
payı da 2 ile çarparım. 2 kere 3 6/ 2
kere 1 2. Aa bak böyle yazdım. Peki her
üslü sayı aynı zamanda bir köklü sayı
mıydı? O zaman ben bu ifadeyi yazarken
hocam buradaki 2'nin üstüne buradaki
kökün derecesine harikasın yapabilirim.
Hocam ben 2 ile genişletmeyecektim. Ben
3 ile genişletecektim. Tabii ki
yapabilirsin. Üslü sayı olarak 2 üzeri 3
k 3 9 3 k 1 3 e bu bir üslü ifade. Ben
bu üslü ifadeyi köklü yazamıyor muydum?
yazıyordum elbet. Şuradaki 9 2'nin
üstüne geldi. Şuradaki 3 kökün
derecesine geldi. Hadi geçmiş olsun.
Bunlar aslında aynı köklü ifadedir.
Niye? Özünde doğduğu yer 2 üssü 3'tür.
Bak ikisinin de özünde çıkış noktası
neresi? 2 üssü 3'ten geldi. O zaman bu
ifadeler de birbirine eşit. Demek ki ben
köklü ifadelerde köklerin derecesini
istersem ya genişletebilirim ya da
sadeleştirmeyile küçültebilirim.
He. O zaman gel bunu teorik olarak
verelim. Kökün derecesi ile kök
içerisindeki üstlü ifadenin kuvveti aynı
pozitif tam sayıyla ile çarpılabilir ya
da ortak bir sayıya bölünebilir. Aynı
sayıyla çarparsam ki biz buna genişletme
diyeceğiz. Örneğin bak kökün derecesi n
x'in üstünde m var. İkisini de k ile bak
birini değil ha. Ulan en çok yapılan
hata burada sazanlanmayalım. Sakın sakın
sazanlanma. İkisini birden çarpacaksın.
Sadeleştirmede hocam ikisini birden
böleceksin. En önemli adım burada bu.
Sadeleştirmede de k hem M'yi hem de N'yi
ne yapmak zorunda? Tam bölmek zorunda.
Hocam ben işte böldüm ama tam
bölünmüyor. Yok öyle bir dünya. Tam
bölünecek. Kural bu. Mesela bak bunu.
Şimdi aşağıdaki ifadede köklü ifadelerin
derece genişletme işlemlerini yaparak
boşlukları dolduracağız. Hocam bak
burada derece kaç? 2. dereceyi kaça
götürmüşüm? 4e bunu bir üstlü sayı gibi
düşün. 5 üssü 1/2 mi var burada? Ben
burada ne yazdıracağım? 4. 4 yazdırmak
için 2 ile mi genişleteceğim? 2 ile
genişletince 5in kares/ 4 derece zaten
yazılmış. O zaman ben buraya 5in karesi
yazdım. Aslında bak buradan buraya
geçerken 2 ile mi çarptım? O zaman
buradan buraya geçerken de üssü 2 ile
çarpacağım. Gel şimdi bir altındaki
hocam burada ne yazıyor? Hiçbir şey
yazmazsa 2. 2'den kaça geçmişim? 3'e ne
ile çarpmışım? 3te. O zaman bunu da 3ile
çarpacağım. Birini ne ile çarpıyorsan
diğerini de çarpıyorsun. Hocam burası da
2 üssü. 3 kere 3'ten ne olur? 9.
Anlaştık mı? Devam. Hocam kaçtaydın?
10'daydın kökünün derecesi. Pardon
5'teydin. 10'a gitmişsin. Çarpı 2
demişsin. O zaman buna da çarpı 2
diyeceksin. 2 üssü ne oldu? Burası 8
oldu zaten. Bak üslü sayı biçiminde
yazalım mı? 2 üssü 4/ 5. Ya da şunu yaz.
2 üssü 8/10. E aynı şey hocam. 2'ye
böldüm 4, 2'ye böldüm 5. E zaten aynı
şey. Bir şey değişmediğini söyledim
hocam. Bak kökün derecesi 3. Kaça gitti?
9'a. Kaçla çarptım? 3'le. O zaman bunu
da 3 ile çarpacağım. O zaman burası 7
üssü 3. Bitti. Şuradan şuraya geçiş.
Kökün derecesi kaç kat artmış? 3 kat
artmış. Burası da 3 kat artacak. Yani 3
üssü 2 kere 3'ten 6. Gel. 6'ymış. Kaç
katına gitmiş? 2 katına. O zaman burası
da 2 katına gidecek hocam. 6. O zaman 5
üssü 2 kere 2'den 4. Köklerin
derecelerini bu şekilde yazacağız.
Buraya kadar tamam mıyız hocam? Süper.
Gel o zaman şimdi 64. soruya.
Hocam biz genişletebildiğimiz gibi aynı
sürede ne yapabilirim? Sadeleştirerek de
bu süreci yönetebilirim. E geldim 8
dereceden kökteydim. 4'e geçtim. Ne
yapmışım? 2'ye bölmüşüm. O zaman bunu da
aslında 2 ile sadeleştirmişim. Misal bak
şunu şöyle hayal et. Hocam burası 3 üssü
6/8. Nasıl yaptım? Bunun derecesini
üste, bunun derecesini alta yazdım.
Sadeleştirme var. Sadeleştirdim. İkisini
de 2'ye böldüm. 3. 2'ye böldüm. 8'i 4.
Bu 3'ün üstüne 3 üssü 3. Bu arkadaş da
kökün derecesine. Zaten öyle yapılmış.
Var mı sıkıntı? Yok. Kaça böldüğümüze
bakıyoruz bu sefer? Kaça bölmüşüm? 3'e.
O zaman bunu da 3'e böleceğim. 9'u 3'e
böldün. 3 5 üsü 3 bitti. Gel. 8'den kaça
gelmişim? 3'e. Kaça bölmüşüm? 6'ya. Bunu
da 6'ya böleceksin. 2 üssü 6'ya böldüm
2'dir. Anlaşılmayan bir nokta yoktur
eminim. Gel buraya hocam. Kaça bölmüşüm?
5'e bölmüşüm. 3 kere 5 15 çünkü. O zaman
bunu da 5'e böleceğim. 10'u 5'e böldüm.
Ne geldi? 2in karesi. Hatta hatta bak 3.
dereceden √2 karesinden de 4 geldi. Oldu
mu? Geldim buraya. Hocam buradan buraya
2'ye bölmüşüm. Bunu da 2'ye böleceğim. O
zaman burada ne kalır? 7in karesi. E
onun da cevabı mesela 7 dereceden kök. 7
kere 7'den ne gelir? 49. Geldim bu
tarafa. Hocam burada hiçbir şey
yazmıyor. 2 yazıyor. Kaça bölmüş? 5'e. O
zaman sen de 5'e böleceksin. 5'e böldüm.
Ne kaldı? 6 üssü 3 kaldı. 216 olar o da.
Hani bulmaya da gerek yok gerçi.
Bırakalım öyle. Tamam. 64. soruya kadar
geldik. Burada noktayı koyuyorum. En
önemli yer köklü ifadelerin
sıralanışları ki özellikle buradan çok
güzel sorular geliyor arkadaşlar. Biraz
daha sağlam sorular çözeceğiz. Bilgi
temelli soruda yine rı şeyi düşüreceğiz
tempoyu ama beceri temelli de özellikle
şu 4üncü soru yok mu? Efsane bir soru.
Onun da animasyonunu yaptık geçen gün.
rtayfa.com YouTube kanalımıza.com yok
rmtayfa YouTube kanalına gir. Shortar
bölümüne yap. Bak buranın animasyonunu
yaptık. Çok güzel oldu. İnşallah
beğenirsiniz. Yine buradaki sorularla
devam edeceğiz. Sonra köklü ifadelerde
toplamasıydı, çıkarmasıydı en zevkli
bölümlere gidiyoruz ama adım adım
ilerlemeye devam. Yorumlarda hepinizi
göreceğim. Yoklama alacağım arkadaş.
Hangi ilden kimler var? Herkes yazsın
yorumlara. Bir sonraki videoda
okuyacağım. Anlaştık mı? Kendine iyi
bak. Hoş kal.